[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much my friend
thank you dear compatriots thank you
on this sunday the 10th of april there
were more than 35 million of you
who decided
[Applause]
and you've acquired this right to vote
and i'd like to thank all our
compatriots
and from the very first round
you have
voted for me
thank you
to
introduce this project progress openness
and french independence and european
independence that we've defended
throughout this campaign
[Applause]
night at my side and over the past few
years
everywhere throughout the country
you have given your energy and your work
your days and nights have been devoted
and that's what i owe you and i'm well
aware of it
[Applause]
[Music]
all of you
past six years up until this evening
you've worked along my side i'd like you
to overcome your differences to gather
together in a major political movement
of unity and of action for our country
[Applause]
all
the candidates that were present in the
first round natalia
nicolas
[Music]
[Music]
to applaud them would you be kind enough
to applaud them
[Applause]
because from the beginning
defend our convictions
but we also respect
everyone and thank you for that
[Applause]
you see
i'm aware the deception they
the candidates that i've just mentioned
are disappointed
and their supporters and their electors
must be disappointed our democracy
is
full of people committed who defend
their ideas with strength and passion
thank you to them
[Applause]
and i'd also like to thank
this evening have said that they will
support me
[Applause]
[Music]
and whatever their choices were in the
first round please join us
[Applause]
i know it's a choice made by jean-luc
melanchol for example
[Applause]
i would also like to
salute
[Applause]
i would
all kinds of convictions and different
sensitivities
so as to be able to build with them
joint action at the service of our
nation in the coming years and that's
our responsibility
[Applause]
they have decided to choose abstention
or extreme votes either because they're
angry or because of the inequalities
that still exist
ecological disorder
lack of security on a daily basis the
difficulty to uh live with dignity if
when you work hard or else they feel
that they're not sufficiently
represented
listened to
i want to convince you
that in the coming days that our program
is far more solid than that of the
extreme right and we will take into
consideration their fears and the
challenges
over time
[Music]
and the debate that we'll have in the
coming couple of weeks will be decisive
as far as our country is concerned and
as far as europe is concerned
in france
level technological level economic and
military level agricultural and cultural
levels
do you want to have a france
and it's able to finance its welfare
state retirement schools hospitals and
our public services
[Music]
we want to have a france that will face
up to ecological climate changes through
nuclear
renewable energies
and planning the environment
france through
the
environment we'll be able to reduce uh
energy costs and electric cars will
replace all of those petrol cars
do we want to have a fairer france
for those overseas throughout the
territories
again do we want to have a fraud that's
faced with the crises that will still
happen
we want to still have trust in science
reason
competency just as we've done over the
past few months in the past few years
[Music]
of france
that fights resolutely
against islamist separatism but through
secularism allows everyone to believe or
to not or not to believe
and to
be able to carry out
their practice their religion
i don't want a france that won't allow
the muslims or the jews not to eat what
they are supposed to eat according to
their religion that's not us
i want to have a france
that will ensure progress for everyone
for the our elders for our children for
the workers for the families for women
and single mothers for people who are
living in preparation i want to have a
france
where
we'll ensure progress for everyone we
don't want there to be regression for
everyone i want france to be within a
strong europe and carry on establishing
alliances with the great democracies in
order to defend itself
not of france that will get out of
europe
[Applause]
i want to have a france fidel
thank you
what's at stake on the 24th of april
well there'll be
choices to your vote
you'll be able to
vote in 15 days and i'd like to say
tonight that i will do my utmost to
convince everyone that the only plan as
far as purchasing power is
[Applause]
a life that's expensive is ours
i'm the only plan
[Applause]
[Applause]
all of us whatever our opinions and our
beliefs are i believe in all of us
and that's what france is
[Applause]
[Music]
convince everyone that on the 24th of
april
we can make the choice for a new french
epoch
on the 24th of april we're able to
use
our history on the 24th of april we were
able to make the choice for france and
europe together
[Applause]
long live
and long live france
welcome
[Applause]